Voiceover:We've been drawing analogies
between I guess we could say
traditional multiplication,
or scalar multiplication,
and the first one we drew is
when you have traditional multiplication,
you multiply 1 times any number
and you get that number again.
And you could view 1 as
essentially the identity.
The identity number,
or this is the identity
property of multiplication.
You multiply 1 times any number,
you get that number again.
And that essentially inspired our thinking
behind having identity matrices.
Said hey, maybe there are some matrices
that if I multiply
times some other matrix,
I'm going to get that matrix again.
And you've probably shown for yourselves
that you can do it in either way.
You could have some matrix
times an identity matrix
and get that matrix again.
Now if matrix A right over
here is a square matrix,
then in either situation,
this identity matrix
is going to be the same identity matrix.
But if matrix A is not a square matrix,
then these are going to be
two different identity matrices,
depending on the appropriate dimensions.
Now, let's see if we
can extend this analogy
between traditional multiplication
and matrix multiplication.
We know that there's
another spacial number
in traditional multiplication,
and that's a 0.
So, we know that 0 times
anything is equal to 0.
Or, anything times 0 is equal to 0.
So what would be the analogy
if we're thinking about
matrix multiplication?
Well, it would be some matrix that
if I were to multiply
it times another matrix,
I get, I guess you could say
that same 0 matrix again.
And that is what we call it.
We call it a 0 matrix.
So if I take some matrix
A, and essentially,
if I multiply it times
one of these 0 matrices,
or I multiply one of
the 0 matrices times A,
I should get another 0 matrix.
And it depends on the dimensions.
You might not get a 0 matrix
with the same dimensions.
It depends what the dimensions
of A are going to be, but you could image
what a 0 matrix might look like.
For example, if A is 1,2,3,4,
what's a 0 matrix that I could multiply
this by to get another 0 matrix?
Well, it might be pretty straight forward,
if you just had a ton of zeros here,
when you multiply this out,
you're going to get this -
you date the dot product of
this row and this column.
0 times 1 plus 0 times 3 is going to be 0.
You keep going, 0,0,0,0.
If we had a - just to
make the point clear -
let's say we had a matrix 1,2,3,4,5,6.
So over here, we want
to multiply this times -
let's see, in order for
the matrix multiplication
to work, my 0 matrix has got to have
the same number of columns
as this one has rows,
so it's got to have 2 columns,
but I could make it have 3 rows.
So it could look like this, 0,0,0,0
and I encourage you to multiply these two.
Pause the video right
now, and see what you get.
Well when you multiply
them, let's think about it.
So the top left entry -
so let me just write the dimensions.
This is a 3x2 matrix, this is a 2x3matrix.
So, we know that we have
valid matrix multiplication
going on right over same here.
The number of columns in the first matrix
is equal to the number of
rows in the second one.
And we also know that
the resulting product
is going to be a 3x3 matrix.
So it's going to be a 3x3 matrix,
and I'll leave it up to you to verify
that all the entries
here are going to be 0.
And it makes sense, you
could go through the math,
but you can see, well
you're just everytime,
you're multiplying say
this row by this column
to get that entry, we'll just have
0 times 1 plus 0 times
4 to get that 0 there.
But the whole point of
showing you this example is,
we have one 0 matrix multiplying
by this matrix right over here,
and then we get another 0 matrix
but it has different dimensions.